you know maybe they should just go ahead
and put a revolving door at Arkham
[Music]
Gotham double feature again this time
because basically the world conspired on
me and I did not have it in me I was too
beat to do last week's episode at the
time that it aired and then other stuff
that I had planned came up so catching
up so last week's episode and this
week's episode so that means I am
talking about the sinking ship and the
great applause as well as my three soups
my three soups are these three soups
what the heck is it it is one of my
three soups yeah I need to look this
things up because if I I say you're
wrong somebody will put it in the
comments so let's go well let's go in
order let's start with the first one the
sinking ship and the great applause this
was great this was the level of madness
that I enjoy and and you know I had an
odd realization watching these episodes
back-to-back there's something about
when insanity happens in day time that I
like better because contrasting these
episodes like this first one happens
mostly during the day you know there's
scenes at the docks middle of the day
there's scenes that are committal of the
day it's I like that there's something
about that I like better than the stuff
set at night I don't know it just feels
more unique maybe unreal it just it
feels more Gotham to me that like our
Court they don't even wait for night
this stuff just happens but in any case
so there's a lot of stuff that I like in
this in this first episode so god I'm
even trying to think of everything to
talk about right off the bat I really am
enjoying watching the development
between Selina and Bruce I loved I loved
them both episodes but in this first one
I loved their scene in the pond
shop and I I love you know Bruce just
throwing down and kind of starting to be
a bit of a badass it was it was good
stuff right this is the problem with
with watching these things back-to-back
as I as I haven't trying to remember
what happened and what what we basically
got the penguin and the Riddler back
together again which was nice if they're
gonna pair them up again that would they
need to be done splitting them apart we
need to be finished with that and you
know if there's an external thing that
drives though apart that's different but
that we need to be done with with the
whole internal strife thing what is
going on with Barbara now that was at
the very end of that episode kind of fed
into the next one so we'll come back to
that you know was well I'm you know I'll
save this because it was like my
favorite thing I liked Sophia being
taken down by Lee that said I was a
little sad to see Sophia go down at all
because she kind of grew on me it's
funny a lot of the Gotham characters
take a little while to really click into
place for me it was the case for Barbara
who at this point one of my favorite
characters like ever in television and
it was it took me a while with Sophia
and I think it wasn't until her plans
stopped always falling exactly as she
wanted them and then basically the
brattiness started to come out of her
and I found her more interesting more
compelling and more just engaging as a
villain and of course despite the Fagin
being shot dead center of the head she's
in a coma instead of dead Gotham I also
like that that Lee Lee went there Lee
pulled the trigger
the moment that I loved in this episode
and it's just phenomenal was Harvey
talking to Jim and G coz Jim says you
know that he's gonna confess
you know to his part in all this and and
the deal he struck with Sophia and what
happened the pig and Harvey just tells
them no because that doesn't help
anybody but you
you'll feel better but you'll have done
damage and the GCPD will lose confidence
in you and they will fall apart the only
person who benefits this from you
confessing is you so you want to be a
good guy you take it you take the pain
you swallow it down you keep it inside
it and you do whatever you have to do to
numb it and in the case of Harvey it's
drink and this this lines up with what I
was coming to like about Harvey in
general and it really does solidify the
character for me it really is like look
he's not a he's not a great guy in a lot
of ways but he he doesn't just
internalize to be a tough guy he
internalizes because exposing his pain
doesn't help other people there is you
know it's possible to have selfless
isolation for for lack of a better term
and is this basically concept that
Harvey introduces Jim to and I first of
all I like him because I think that's
honestly something that's hardly ever
acknowledged by and large in terms of
our society pop culture in general this
there's this adoration of tell the truth
the truth is always best and sometimes
it's not sometimes telling the truth
you'll feel better if you do but it
won't actually make the situation but it
might might make everything worse there
are times we're telling the truth and
being honest is actually the selfish
thing to do and you do more benefit to
more people by keeping it inside and
just dealing with with what it is
instead of just you know expunging it
and having the world deal with it
instead and that's not a perspective
that happens often in in entertainment
I think it's just nice to see in general
and to see it coming from a character
like Harvey who's a character I like
that was a nice bonus I think that's
most of the things I wanted to hit in
that episode we add while we had the
return of Victor fries and a very nice
episode he's he's developing the
coldness and the personality also Victor
Zsasz god he is so much fun I'm not
thrilled that the I can remember his
friggin name the guy who now has the
eyepatch I'm not thrilled that he's bad
because I didn't really care about him I
kind of just like that he went down like
a punk last time we saw him now I
thought that was gonna be it but I'm
always happy to see zas I mean that's
that's just great stuff so the next
episode let's lead off with Barbara
because she was kind of the cliffhanger
off the previous episode and then into
the next one be one of my three soups so
the whole thing with that well first of
all I got very nervous once that kicked
in because the whole Rachel Ghul thing
unfortunately I think was one of the
weaker elements of this season so far
there was some good that came out of it
its impact on Bruce overall I think has
been a net positive for the character
and it's given him a journey this season
but as a character within the show I
didn't he didn't work for me so when we
got hints at him I what I was afraid
they were gonna do I was afraid they
were gonna pull an agents of shield and
have like race like take over Barbara
now he's like possessing her then she's
not even Barbara anymore she's she's now
this other character I don't even like
as much like they did on agents of
shield with Ward where the character
died and then became possessed and you
know the actor still walking around but
the character I liked is gone and this
much more boring things lagering I was
so afraid of that and it doesn't look
like that's what's happening
so the League of Shadows I
it felt a little Hempfest a little
contrived that all the female members
killed all the male members because they
were weak or wouldn't accept Barbara's
the leader but at the same time
logistically I'm totally down for
pairing the League of Assassins down to
a relatively small number because just
otherwise it can get too unwieldy and it
could have ended up reminding me too
much of the hand from Iron Fist and the
defenders and blue so I think stripping
it down to something more basic was a
good call narrative Lee speaking
and I will be curious to see all that
pans out obviously the big centerpiece
of the second episode is the other big
breakout from Arkham with scarecrow and
Jerome and an attached now I'm hoping
they have scarecrow gets more to do in
the next episode because right now he
feels kind of superfluous cuz Tech
certainly kept people busy Jerome's
obviously got his own thing going on
right now he usually does overall this
episode was fine it's the kind of one
I'm tempted to skip over on re-watch as
though not because it's bad but because
it's it's largely a setup episode it's
laying the groundwork for whatever gonna
is gonna come next because we just had a
pretty sizable shaking up with the death
of Sophia and so now we're leading into
here's the new resources Barbara's gonna
have and sort of here's a general idea
of what Jerome and his guys are up to so
you know you get you get feels for it
but it doesn't have as many like big
yeah moments that said there are two
things that I really I really did enjoy
one Gordon solution to the jumpers on
the ledges that was perfect and like
oddly straight-faced and sincere in its
sentiment because I could have been
really cheesy this whole idea of you
know you can't tell them to save
themselves because I've already
hypnotized them that if
someone tells them say themselves they
will jump and he says save each other
and there's something about that that
not only it was a clever workaround but
also so wonderfully symbolic of just
everything you know that they are you
know gonna reach out and I can't save
myself but I can save you and together
maybe we can all save each other it's
yeah surprisingly touching and played
just right I think the other thing that
I really liked from the second episode
and this was this was a relatively
smaller moment but it was it's basically
Selina dressing down Bruce and saying
Bruce your ego when he's saying how the
fact that he didn't kill Jerome makes
him somewhat responsible for anything
Jerome does she's just like dude it's
not all about you which first of all it
was nice in the moment but also more
people need to tell Batman to get over
himself honestly and I know he's not
Batman yet but like yes I like Batman
but dude dude come on
so that I love that that made me very
very happy
and also like the whole thing with
Selina you know sort of finding it
difficult to return the the jewelry and
having a hard time basically I was gonna
say facing the consequences I'm not sure
that's even it I think she just the idea
of asking for forgiveness is a very
foreign concept to her in the first
place and I think the the whole thing in
her mind is just weird like she has a
hard time wrapping her head around it
and I think that that that plays well in
this in this episode too
I think that's about it that's most of
the major things I wanted to hit the the
the first of these two so basically last
week's episode is the better of the two
it was a nice at least for the time
since she's in a coma not dead clothes
out for Sophia's story and this the next
one was a decent setups one I will be
really curious to see what happens after
this
I mean Jerome's out and about so
generally speaking you're gonna be
talking about a wild ride when that
happens so I think that'll just about
wrap this one up Gotham latest two
episodes I'm I will try to avoid falling
behind again I'm really sorry it just
look it happens sometimes but in any
case have you seen him what did you
think about him whatever your thoughts
are drop something down the comments
let's talk about it all the stuff to do
such as support me on patreon like it
like this stuff subscribe follow me on
Twitter links for all this stuff and
even more stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]